en douleur et au deuxième trimestre de
sa grossesse progembloux s'est présenté
en joueur 2020 à l'hôpital miséricordiat
pour y recevoir des soins
deux ans plus tard et toujours
bouleversé cette femme crie de la
Première nation big Stone raconte
aujourd'hui comment elle en est ressorti
humilié et sans son bébé
avoir à se battre pour sa vie à compo
gamebler des détails entourant son
accouchement son troublant la femme dit
cette présentait l’hôpital sur la
recommandation de son médecin mais dès
son arrivée le personnel médical lui
hostile racontait au sérieux sa
souffrance
particulièrement brusque lors d'un
examen les laissant dans une grande
douleur elle est son conjoint a ensuite
été laissé à eux-mêmes et soutient avoir
accouché sans aide sous les yeux de
l'infirmier qui serait resté figé
pendant l'accouchement
son bébé serait mort quelques minutes
après avoir été finalement pris en
charge par les personnel hospitalier
traitement ne serait jamais arrivé une
femme blanche comme moi dit son avocate
deux ans plus tard peu au Game bleu veut
te tenir justice et réparation elle
réclame près d'un million 400000 dollars
à l'administration de l'hôpital une
gynécologue obstétricienne
toutes les histoires sont
malheureusement trop fréquentes dans le
système de santé dit le grand chef
unturnowski première nation à tabasca
tupperwan réclame également une enquête
publique sous le racisme systémique dans
les hôpitaux albertin quand le
gestionnaire de l'hôpital dit ne pas
être en mesure de commenter de corps
médicaux spécifiques mais l'hôpital
affirme toutefois prendre très au
sérieux toute plainte de racisme y
ajoute que la discrimination n'a pas sa
place au sein de son établissement ici
Mathieu Gohier Radio-Canada Edm